So for setting up the controls for our car, we're going to be using the enhanced input system.
Now, the enhanced input system uses two primary assets.
There is the input action and the input mapping context.
And we use these to drive our throttle, our steering and our brakes.
Now, as it says here, the input action is a representation of something that your player can do.
So for us, it's like our throttle, steering and brakes, so accelerating and steering and braking.
And the input mapping context is sort of the parent of these input actions.
And you use that to describe the rules for what can trigger any of the input actions.
So let's take a look and see how we get those things set up.
So back in our engine, I'm just going to come back one folder and create a new folder just to try and keep things organized.
And I'll just call this controls.
And inside here, we're going to create two input actions.
One will be for our throttle and our steering and the other will be for our handbrake.
So if I right click and I come to input, we have input action as an option here.
So we'll create one of those. I'll call that IA throttle steering.
And if I control D to duplicate that, I'll call that IA brake.
So this will represent the ability to accelerate and to steer.
And this will represent the ability to use our handbrake basically.
So if we open up the throttle and steering input action first,
this is where we're going to configure the settings to determine what sort of output information this asset is going to give us.
So for the throttle and steering, the type of output information that we want is directional information from our keyboard inputs.
So for example, when I'm holding W, I want to be able to accelerate.
And when I'm holding A, I want to be able to turn left, holding D, turn right.
So this will be two different axes of information basically.
X will be our forwards and backwards axis and Y will be our steering, our left and right axis.
So to set that up under the value type heading here, we're going to change that to axis 2D.
So that's a vector 2D which would give us those two axes, the X and the Y axis.
And we want those to trigger only when we're holding these keys.
So we don't want to just tap the key and have it infinitely accelerate.
We want to be holding the key all the time and it only be accelerating when we're holding, the same with steering.
So to do that, we need to add a trigger.
So under the triggers heading here, we'll add an element and we'll change that to hold.
And if I pop open the index, you see we get a hold time threshold here.
And this is saying that, okay, you can hold it for one second and nothing will happen until that second has elapsed.
So because we want it to be instant, I'm just going to change that to zero.
Otherwise there'll be like a one second delay before the car will start turning left or right or start accelerating.
So if I just save that now, we can move on to our braking.
Now this is going to work in a slightly different way.
This is going to be our handbrake.
So we don't need any directional information from this.
We just simply need to know, is this on or is this off?
So is it true or is it false?
And the default value type of a bool works perfectly for that because that's the information that it gives us.
So we'll leave that as it is.
And the only thing we want to do is add a trigger again.
And we need to add the same trigger, so we just want to hold this.
Meaning that every time we hold this, for example spacebar, the handbrake will activate.
And again, I'm going to set the hold time threshold to zero so that, you know, there's no delay in activating the handbrake.
So we have our two input actions set up and they're giving us the information that we need.
So we've got the directional information for the throttle and the steering.
And then we have the true or false information from the handbrake or the brake input action.
And this is where we'll set up our key mapping.
So determining which buttons on our keyboard will give us what information from the input actions.
So let's create our input mapping context.
So right clicking back up to input and selecting input mapping context.
I'm going to call this IMC.
I'll just put controls.
And if I open that up, you see there's not much in here until we start adding mappings.
So if we add one mapping, this will essentially look for the input actions that you have in your project.
So we've got the brake, if I close that down, and we've got the throttle and steering.
Now the brake is quite a simple setup.
So if I just pop that open, press the keyboard icon here and then press spacebar.
That'll input the key mapping that we want.
You could also search for it in here if it's not on the keyboard, it's on the gamepad or something, for example.
But we don't need to add any triggers because we've already set that up.
And we don't need to add any modifiers because the information that we want from this is just the true or false bool.
So when we're pressing this button, so spacebar, we want it to give us the true output, which it will by default.
And when we let go, it will give us the false output.
So there's nothing more we need to do for that.
In the throttle and steering, however, we're going to need more than just one input key.
We're going to need W, A, S and D.
We're going to need four of them so we can drive forward and backwards and then steer left and right.
So if I add two more of those, just minimize them a little bit, we have W, S, A and D.
So these are the keys that we want to use to extract different information from the input action.
And if you remember, it was the vector 2D.
So that's the X axis information and the Y axis information.
So our X axis is going to be our W and S, our forwards and backwards.
And our Y axis is going to be the A and the D, so our turning or steering left and right.
By default, the information that comes out of the input action is the positive X value.
And we know that our vehicle is facing along the positive X axis, so that's going to be the forward direction for our vehicle.
So that means if I pop this open here, we don't need to add any triggers or modifiers to the information that's being output when we press W.
And because we want to find that positive X value.
And that's what we're getting by default.
But with the S input, we do need to add a modifier because we need to find the negative X axis, which means we'll be able to reverse.
So if we add plus here on the modifiers tab, and then choose the drop down and choose negate.
What this is going to do is essentially invert the values that have been spat out by the input action.
So by default, we get the positive X, if we negate that, that will give us the negative X axis.
And that's what we're going to use to be able to reverse the vehicle.
Next, looking at our steering with A and D, we're going to need to use a modifier to help us find the Y axis.
So if we add a new modifier, and from the drop down box, we choose swizzle input axis values.
Now what this is going to do is essentially convert the X axis into the Y axis and give us that Y axis output.
But because our A key we want to turn left, we know that that information also needs to give us the negative values.
So we can add a second modifier here.
And from the drop down, choose negate.
So this is going to do is find the Y axis and then invert the values.
So give us the negative values.
And for D, because we need the positive values, the only modifier we need to add is the swizzle input axis values modifier.
So just to go over these again, if I pop them all open, our brake will be using spacebar,
and we don't have any modifiers or any triggers on there.
So it's just going to give us the true or false response.
Then for W, we'll be getting the positive X axis, which is the default value.
For S, we've added a modifier to flip that default value so that it's negative.
So it gives us the negative X value.
And then for A and D, we've added the swizzle input axis values to find the Y axis instead.
And just for A, we've also added in a gate modifier so that we can flip those Y axis.
So they have one that turns in the positive direction and one that turns in the negative direction.
Now that we have the logic set up for our input actions,
we can go back to our vehicle blueprint and create the logic to read this information
and use it to drive things like the throttle and the brakes and the steering
and actually get our vehicle moving.
Back inside our vehicle blueprint here, if we open up the event graph,
this is where we're going to be setting up all of the logic to trigger certain events
like our throttle and steering and braking
with the key presses that we just set up in the input mapping context.
Now the first thing we need to do is enable the input mapping context that we just created
so that the blueprint knows where to read the information from.
And we're going to do that on event begin play.
So we don't need these two events here, we're just going to delete those.
And I'll drag off event begin play and I'll cast to, or search for,
cast to player controller.
And this is going to access the player controller that we input here.
And the target for this is going to be itself, so this blueprint.
So if I just search for get controller,
I default the target itself unless we put something else into this input pin here.
And next we need to actually find the enhanced input local player subsystem,
which is the controller system we're going to reference.
So if I right click search for enhanced input local player subsystem,
it's actually the other one that we needed there.
So enhanced input local player subsystem, there we go.
And then we need to make sure that this is valid.
So if we drag up and search for is valid,
we need to use the is valid with the question mark just here, the query.
And then I'll just connect that logic up.
The last thing we need to do is add the mapping context off the end of this.
So if this is valid, we want it to reference the input mapping context that we just created.
So if I right click search for add mapping context,
under the dropdown heading here,
it's going to give us access to all of the input mapping context assets within the project.
And obviously it's just the one that we created.
So just at the top of the list here, we'll set that up.
And then we'll actually add the target and connect that to the enhanced input local player subsystem.
If I compile and save that.
With this logic, the blueprint is now reading from the mapping context that we've created.
So any logic we do from now on will be based on these inputs.
So let's set up the logic for our braking system first.
So I'm just going to right click and search for our action input.
Oops.
And we want to search for the AI brake, sorry, IA brake enhanced input action.
And when this is triggered, we want to set the handbrake input.
So if I search for set handbrake input,
the target is going to be the vehicle movement component.
So what we can do actually is just drag that into the world here,
into the graph rather and have that be our target.
And the input is going to be the action value that is given out when we press and release the space bar.
So the key that we inputted as our input action.
And if we just connect those up together there.
That's essentially all the logic we need to do for the braking system.
It's quite straightforward.
When it comes to the steering and the throttle, it gets a little bit more complex
because we want to essentially break out the individual axes, X and Y,
as well as the positive and negative variants of those.
So the first thing we'll do is find the throttle and steering input.
And you can see we have the same options here.
We have our action value and the triggered pin we're going to use these two.
So our action value is, as you can see, is a vector 2D,
which means it's giving off more information than our bool above for the braking system.
And that means we're going to need to sort of break that information into its two channels,
so into the X and the Y channels.
So I'm going to pull off there and search for brake vector 2D.
And that will give us the X and the Y channels.
So now we have access to what we set up for the W and the S keyboard inputs
and the A and the D keyboard inputs, which will affect the Y channel or the Y axis.
So now that we've split this information, what we can do is start setting up the throttle.
So I'm going to search for set throttle input.
And again, dragging the vehicle movement component as our target.
And we want to connect the X axis here,
because the default X axis is what we're going to use as our W, our forward, our throttle input.
So let's just connect up that logic.
Now we set up the reverse with the brake input event or function, should I say.
So if I search for set brake input rather than the set handbrake input,
as long as on your vehicle component we have reverse as brake checked,
using this set brake input will actually both slow the car down if it's going forwards
and then enter reverse if you continue to hold S in this case.
But that's only valid when we use the negative values.
So to access the negative values on the X axis, we will multiply the output by minus one
and then connect that logic up there.
And we'll make sure we connect the execute as well.
And the next thing we can set up is the steering.
And that reads directly from the Y output.
So what I'm going to do here, just shift those over a little bit
and search for set steering input.
I connect those guys up and drag the Y pin over to our steering input here.
Just going to double click that so we get a couple of reroute nodes
that we can use to just see the information a little more clearly.
And that's it as far as it goes for our input actions.
So we're setting our throttle input with the positive X value.
Then we're setting our brake, which we're also using as reverse
because we've got the use brake as reverse option ticked.
I just search for that just to make sure.
Reverse as brake.
And we're using the negative X axis for that.
And then we're setting our steering input based on the Y values.
So we've set up our input actions.
We've determined which buttons on our keyboard
we want to trigger these different actions with our mapping context.
And our blueprint is now reading from all of our information
to set our brakes and our throttle and our steering.
The final thing we need to do is to tell the project to use this information
when we press play in the level.
And we do that with a game mode blueprint.
So coming back into our content browser here,
if I right click and we create a new blueprint,
we'll choose game mode base as the parent class.
And I'm just going to call this gm underscore, let's just say driving.
And double click this to open.
Inside here in the details panel,
all we need to change is the default pawn class.
And we're going to tell that to use our BP chaos vehicle.
And that's the blueprint that we've been adding this
or setting up all of this logic within.
So inside our level here, inside the world settings tab,
which if you don't have open, you can come to window
and then open with world settings here.
Under the game mode override, we're going to choose
our gm driving game mode blueprint.
And if I move a little lower down here,
when we hit play, we should see our vehicle spawn.
And when I hold W, we're going forwards.
And A will go left, D will go right.
And when I hold S, that breaks and then reverses.
So now we have our vehicle set up and driving around the scene.
Next, we'll take a look at some of the settings
that we can use to tweak the feel of this vehicle,
like the suspension and the steering and the grip,
that sort of thing.
So you can start customizing the look
and the feel of your own vehicle for your own projects.